ash's clients have been seeing
incredible weight loss results
when it comes down to it it's more than
diet and exercise
before dr nash i was a junk food junkie
and lord size 14
but now i'm a size 6 8 and no longer
addicted to junk food
life-changing results for norma dr nash
tell us more about her
so norma came to my office believe it or
not jc norma came to my office about
seven
years ago she was a complete junk food
junkie
had a raging sugar addiction that she
couldn't seem to be
thought it was mental behavior and
willpower when actually what she was
dealing with is something called a
candida infection
when we were able to fix the candida
overgrowth she went to a size six
eight and she is still that size what is
candida what is it exactly
yeah so candida albicans is a yeast or a
fungus that is supposed to be present in
very
small amounts in the colon the problem
is for a large majority
of americans especially after the
pandemic this yeast and fungus has
overgrown and it is bloomed and it's
going throughout the body
not only does that damage the immune
system and make it hard for us to fight
off things like virus and bacteria
but it can cause a weight gain of 32
pounds a year jc
so what are symptoms of candida then
what are we looking for
symptom-wise yeah so you know the
problems is like the symptoms are going
to be on the screen and what people are
going to notice is the symptoms sound
like all the other symptoms right so
we're gonna see
weight gain and difficulty losing weight
we're gonna see cravings for sugar
and so the problem is the symptoms just
sound too much like all the other
symptoms so what if there was a way to
test it
right from home and there is a way to
test it tell her i know the test tell
everyone about the test
it's like i set it up yeah so there is a
test
for you to find out do you have this
yeaster fungus and is it overgrown you
take a clear glass of water
and first thing in the morning before
you put anything in the mouth you're
going to deposit some saliva into that
clear glass
if in within 60 90 seconds you start
seeing white material dropping down like
legs into the water
that's the actual yeast or fungus it
means it has overgrown to the point it
is in your saliva
it means you have an overgrowth not only
is your immune system being damaged but
you're getting a stubborn weight problem
as well
someone does have the candida what do
they do well what they need to do is a
very specific protocol to break down and
extract that toxin out of
all of the cells of their body so a lot
of times the over-the-counter remedies
just aren't enough so we have specific
protocols that we use when people know
that they have a candida overgrowth
to help them not only get rid of the
yeast and the toxin and bring it back
into normal levels in the gut
but then that's also going to speed up
and accelerate their fat loss as well
if you have the candida you call dr nash
that's what you do
and every week you bring a special to
the show what do you have for us this
week
i do so obviously one of the things we
would want you to do after this show is
do that candida test see if you have it
now if you do
then we want to set up the evaluation to
help you get
rid of it normally that's 97 but if you
talk
to my staff or if you go online at the
website we're showing you'll get it for
9.97 but i only have 10 spots available
because
it is crazy right now with all the
people that are wanting to do the
program